I want to talk about German Chancellor
Angela Merkel who is now calling for a
burka ban in Germany the backstory of
this was our discussion about with Trump
being elected president of the United
States who is going to be the so-called
leader of the free world it's not going
to be Trump that's for sure it's pretty
embarrassing to have Donald Trump as
president and we speculated that German
Chancellor Angela Merkel might be a
pretty good choice in terms of who would
be seen as the leader of the free world
she has now formally endorsed a full
burqa ban and some speculation is that
this is a sort of PR counter to the
backlash for being seen as lenient on
immigration policies in Germany and she
made these comments at a Christian
Democratic Union conference she recently
also declared that she's seeking
re-election and even that reelection is
being considered as a possible reaction
to the election of Donald Trump in the
United States and she said to a big
group at this event to a large round of
applause the full veil must be banned
wherever it is legally possible now
you'll remember that six years ago in
2010 France passed a burka ban it bans
the wearing of face covering headgear
it's not just the burqa it includes
masks it includes helmets it includes
balaclavas and niqabs and other veils
covering the face in public places
except under specific circumstances that
ban also applies to the burqa
understandably if it covers the face now
arguments in favor of a burqa ban are
it's not religious freedom to conceal
your identity in public and it's
actually a risk for crime to enter
public places anonymously it's cultural
not religious and therefore it doesn't
infringe on anyone's right to believe
what they want to believe religiously
although the counter-argument to that is
that the way you're dressed is part of
the free practice of religion and also
that the burqa is a religious item and
thus banning it is not freedom of
religion is one of the big arguments
against banning the burqa now many hate
the burqa because it represents
controlled by men over women in Islam
counter to that though Pat is that if
you tell women you can't wear this
you're also controlling women's bodies
aren't you yeah I guess it's a catch-22
in that sense I mean I'm pretty split on
this just coming from a more American
perspective of having freedom or village
and having that long tradition but you
know it goes both ways I'm on the fence
about it this is something a lot of our
viewers are actually on the fence about
and I there's no doubt that there's no
way someone should be able to enter a
bank with their face covered it just
makes absolutely no sense you go into a
bank people have to know who you are any
situation where you have to show ID you
can't go in with your face covered you
just can't you need to be able to
confirm that the person on the ID is the
person that's there the argument in
public out on the street is much more
difficult to make but you could pass a
law that says in particular situations
all face coverings must be lifted it
doesn't matter whether it's a mask or a
helmet or a religious item this includes
airport security this includes banks
this might include retail stores
wherever I just don't know that that's a
solution because the biggest debate here
is over oppressive ideology the idea
that well sometimes women make the
choice they want the burqa but are they
making that choice in a way that is
already based on an oppressive ideology
that has been ingrained into them it
ignores though that women do have a
right to dress however they want if
that's how they truly want to but we've
many shows have talked about this just
because a woman says they want the burqa
is it disrespectful to women to say you
don't really want it you only think you
want it because men told you you want it
either way you can make a pretty
compelling case yeah that's the thing
right do they actually believe in the
brainwashing or are they just trying to
appease the the men in their lives the
real issue is not actually about the
logistics of the burka ban as I
mentioned you could say people can dress
however they want but there are certain
scenarios where you cannot wear a face
covering you must be identifiable that
can be done it's more about what the
burqa ban is code for and how
politically advantageous it might be for
Angela Merkel given the perception of
her being weak on him
the conversation about the merits and
failings of a burka ban the logistics of
it relevant important but the real issue
here for Angela Merkel is the blowback
to her being perceived as weak on
immigration send me your thoughts on
this and let's get a discussion going
about it on our discussion forum at
david pakman.com slash reddit Gamefly is
sort of like netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s